let's get to five headlines
[Music]
okay nancy pelosi is the latest democrat
politician to break the shutdown rules
that she pushes and supports and once
again like the mayor of chicago it's all
so that she can get her hair did
as the kids say i think uh here she is
nancy going to a hair salon maskless
indoors
san francisco to get a blowout
whatever that is honestly when i first
heard that nancy pelosi was caught
indoors for a blowout i thought it was
some kind of bathroom emergency
and at first i thought well okay i'll
give her that i mean you know look you
got to do what you got to do
but no apparently it's uh it's some sort
of hair thing so
it's illegal right now in the city to
get your hair done inside especially
maskless
but nancy can do it because she's nancy
pelosi now
the pelosi camp has responded to the
controversy their excuse
their excuse is something else their
excuses that she didn't know
that what she was doing was wrong
seriously that's what they're
saying she didn't know she didn't know
about the rules that she has
ceaselessly promoted and insisted upon
and that's absurd obviously but on
another level in in a certain way i
almost believe it i almost believe
that nancy pelosi really didn't think
she had done anything wrong
but not because she didn't know the
rules but because she really didn't
think they applied to her
now nancy pelosi's been in congress for
376 years i think
so she's been in this bubble uh not
living a real human life for so long
it may just be that she really assumed
that the rules didn't apply to her
i can almost imagine the conversation
with one of her henchmen when they say
uh you know speaker pelosi
people are upset that you went in to
that hair salon
what upset what do you mean well because
it's illegal
and you know you've supported these laws
and now you're doing what people think
of hypocrite
but wait hang on a second but i'm nancy
pelosi did you explain that to them
no did you explain to them i'm nancy
pelosi
do they know that it's it's it's me i
mean i said what do you expect me to
follow the same rules
as the dirty smelly regular people
that's absurd
um and then she soothes herself by
eating five cartons of
ice cream from her 95 000 refrigerator
uh but whatever whatever the excuse is
this
this
just really what it confirms again is
that the people in government
um who've been fear-mongering about the
virus and using it to control us
don't believe what they're saying all
right let's go to number two the media
right now is having a difficult time
uh so prayers up for the media because
they're they're having
it's it's it's a hard time for them
we've got these riots going on
uh but the media can't decide if it
should
deny that the riots are happening or
blame the riots on donald trump that
that's what it really comes down to they
can't figure it out
so they're kind of doing both at the mo
the moment they're trying to split the
difference
and that's why you have this headline
from the new york times uh the headline
is
as right-wing groups increasingly move
to confront protesters in u.s cities
demonstrators are assessing how to keep
themselves safe
uh yes of course
yes that's what's happening here well
with a few with a few tweaks this is a
good headline so
i think it just needs to run through the
editorial process a little bit more
here's how i would adjust it this is
what i would say for the headline
as citizens increasingly decide that
they don't want their houses and
businesses burned down
arsonists are assessing how to continue
their campaign of terrorism
in a way that harms others but not
themselves so
you know very similar but just some
minor changes
anyway that's one strategy to say
yes there's violence but actually
somehow it's all right wingers which
raises the question
if right-wingers are causing all this
violence at left-wing protests
why don't you ever see violence at
right-wing protests i mean you never see
it you never see buildings getting
burned down to right-wing protests
do they save all of that for the
left-wing protests
it's a pretty pretty dastardly genius
plan if so but somehow i doubt it
but then you also have the media at the
same time
claiming that the riots aren't happening
at all
which gives rise to one of my new
favorite genres of tweets where
journalists
in the nicer more comfortable parts of
riot racked towns take pictures and
videos of little plots of grass
where nobody is being beaten unconscious
or killed at the moment
and they offer it as proof that the
riots are fiction so here's dan zak
uh journalist two first names so you
know that you gotta have be on your
guard with this guy
reporter for the washington post and um
i mean if you're like if the last name
zack i don't think you
name your kid dan dan zack
i don't know i i think if you if you've
got the a first name for a last name
then you've got to have a last name for
a first name i think that's the way that
it works
the two first name thing it's creepy
anyway dan zak
uh he he uploaded a little video of some
people sitting on the grass with the
sarcastic caption
washington dc is simply out of control
you see you get it because those six
people there on the grass
aren't murdering anybody right now
therefore there's no problem in dc
makes sense and then josh campbell cnn
correspondent shows us some grass in
portland
with the caption good morning from
wonderful portland where the city is not
under siege
and buildings are not burning to the
ground i also ate my breakfast burrito
outside today
and so far haven't been attacked by
shadowy gangs of antifa commandos
oh okay so josh had a burrito this
morning
and wasn't killed which means logically
that buildings are not burning down in
portland do you understand how that
works
it's airtight you know speaking of which
look i have this uh i
i have this here i found this online
this is a satellite image
of the middle east and as you can see
you know there's nobody in this picture
shooting anyone or blowing themselves up
that we can see
so yeah looks real dangerous all this
stuff about the middle east being
dangerous
you can see look you see syria right
there do you see anyone being executed
by islamic militants in that picture
do you you know what else um
you've probably heard of the hindenburg
disaster supposedly supposedly
allegedly a german airship caught fire
in 1937 killed like 36 people uh that's
what you heard
that's the story but i can debunk that
right now so here's the picture
um but anyway just sorry zoom in on not
on
zoom in on the on the tip of the of the
airship
the part that isn't on fire there you
see see that
the ship didn't catch fire you see
because that
you can see right there that part of the
ship that's not on fire which means that
the other part isn't either just super
scary hindenburg disaster you've got
there
debunked i just did it myself uh
it's it's it's easy to do all right
number three here's a lovely sentiment
from a former blm organizer and
current contributor to medium she says
um
this is a tweet she sent out she says i
absolutely hate the smile that white
people who don't know you give you
walking down the street to let you know
they're a sanctuary safe white
so no problem here just a woman who
hates white people for smiling
imagine being this angry i mean i'm
angry but she gives me a run for my
money i
even i don't get mad at people for
smiling most of the time
but this this is this is extreme like
top
shelf barrel proof racism you're dealing
with right here
where she she is she she hates people of
another race even when they're smiling
not just even winners she hates them for
smiling
uh but this is a blm organizer and
someone who feels
perfectly comfortable expressing this
out loud publicly on the internet
with her own name and face attached to
it which should tell you something
now by the way i checked out her bio on
her website um
and this will shock you first of all she
describes herself as an award-winning
poet educator
author activist and journalist
and also she appears to use the pronoun
they
so both are shocking developments there
and on our twitter account her most
recent retweet
is from someone named feminista jones a
left-wing activist apparently verified
account on twitter
um explicitly calling for and condoning
violence against white people
here's what here's what the she says
feminista jones
begging white people to support blm and
related work has diluted the integrity
of true revolutionary work
i still don't get why folks were so
focused on getting mainstream support
when it only means the inevitable
destruction of the movement
white white people no matter how liberal
or progressive will never endorse
revolutionary acts that may jeopardize
their children's lives
i wonder why and then she continues
violence is the only way of course no
votes no marching
no spots on cable news no high fashion
magazine cover stories no hashtags no
panels
none of that is going to bring about
liberation that black folks deserve
um what if i told you that violence
required the violence required is
liberating what if i told you that
there's no way for a
dislocated displaced african to truly
live free
without the complete destruction of
whiteness's occupation of space in our
minds bodies souls communities etc
and it goes on for a while after that
this is an explicit direct call
for racial violence and it's extremely
common from the blm crew
but somehow the violence is all trump's
fault it's all instigated by right-wing
militias or whatever
meanwhile you have blm organizers
over here saying they're announcing
they're saying no no no guys we're we're
violent
we look we're we we're violent look at
us we we totally support violence
we are so into violence everybody
they're literally
shouting it into megaphones and the
media has their ears plugged pretending
they don't hear it
okay number four a quick one here
headline from the new york post
headline is nearly half of new yorkers
think nyc
is headed in the wrong direction
nearly half which again you know
brings up another new york post headline
from 1912 nearly half of titanic
passengers think ship is headed in the
wrong direction
you know both cases of course um the
real headline is is
the other half what what the hell is the
other half thinking five
finally for our most important story of
the day i wanted to uh um
i want to leave a little bit of time for
this because this is this needs to be
discussed and it's important
an athlete named david rush in idaho has
just
finally broken the record
and you know we've all been waiting for
this moment he's broken record for the
the fastest time to move a cream-filled
cookie from the
forehead to the mouth now the record for
other types of cookies still stands
and of course the record for the fastest
time to move a pancake from the forehead
to the mouth has stood now i think for
2000 years
or something like that um and
okay let's let's just play the footage
so we have the footage here we can play
it
here is again this is david rush
um performing this athletic feed let's
watch this
hey there folks it's david rush on
vacation at the yellowstone national
park entering the guinness world
challenge this week
had to find some off-brand cream-filled
biscuits to attempt to break this
guinness world record thanks to my son
for help
three two one go
eat it
come on hold on all right so we're using
this kind
of creamy sandwich cookies
of course that middle layer in there
three two one go
come on come on well there you go i mean
if we're not watching the nfl anymore at
least we have this
but with our luck you know this guy will
start kneeling too and ruin it
but then i was uh upi.com has the report
on this story i won't read the whole
thing
except at the very end of their report
they say that
they kind of bury the lead they say uh
there was one participant who had a
faster time now
david rush did it at 8.8 seconds there's
another person who actually broke the
record had a faster time
but his attempt was disqualified which
seems like a huge scandal
they don't tell us why he was
disqualified they just gloss over it
but now you know imagine you've trained
your whole life for this moment you've
given everything
to this goal your marriage fell apart
you're estranged from your children you
lost your job you're homeless on the
street
all because you're giving every second
of your life to the goal of eating a
cookie off of your own face
and then you do it and succeed and they
disqualify you
incredible tragedy triumph tragedy drama
joy sorrow
uh that is the world of competitive
competitive whatever the hell this
is we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second but first
you know as part of our daily wire
audience there are a number of ways to
take in the podcast you may listen on
apple podcast
spotify or you know another podcast app
you may also watch on uh on youtube or
facebook or dailywire.com there'll be a
million ways to do it
bottom line we're making our content
available to you anywhere you watch or
listen and now we're introducing a new
upgraded experience daily wire
is now on apple tv and roku so members
can enjoy all of visual elements on this
podcast on your big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or roku and download
today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
walsh and use codewa watch not walsh
use code watch at checkout to get 50 off
your memberships
uh this deal won't last long so act fast
if you wanna if you want live shows on
your big screen plus the one-of-a-kind
highly coveted leftist tears tumblers of
course
then you've got to go to dailywire.com
walsh to get 50 off with code watch
walsh and watch and download the daily
wire on your apple tv and roku today
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
uh be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content